know stacy abrams as the one true
governor of georgia never elected but
still spiritually in charge but she's
more than that
stacy abrams is one of the most talented
and sauciest
romance novelists of a generation but
like so many great artists
she can be underappreciated and that's
why our senior editorial producer the
great tom fox
spent seven dollars to track down a copy
of one of
her steamier novels the 2006 tour de
force
hidden sins now most of the novel is a
mystery and to be honest we didn't
really follow the plot line
that's not because the writing was bad
oh no no
this is amanda gorman level stuff really
it's because our eyes were drawn
reflexively to the more salacious
elements
of the novel like moths to a very very
hot flame how hot well our senior
producer alex mccaskill volunteered to
perform a dramatic
reading of the most titillating moments
in stacey abrams's novel he's still
recovering from that
the recording session began innocently
enough
[Music]
heat like an inferno blazed in his veins
temptation like a song clouded his mind
it demanded that he slide his arms
around her
that he trailed his hand along her spine
to sink into the silken curls at her
knee
heat like an inferno temptation
like a song now we know what you're
thinking grammarians
hitting the similes a bit hard at first
we thought so
but then like a half empty train at penn
station in the middle of the work
week we thought we could just pull away
but we were wrong we had to continue
their tongues tangled danced and she
reveled in the movement
she splayed eager palms against his
chest
and tormented the flesh she found there
too far away she gripped his waist to
pull him closer
until she stood cradled between his hard
thighs
she tormented his flesh with her palms
we were tormented as we read it
as you read it more we noticed our
thighs were also getting harder
much harder but stacey abrams wasn't
done with us yet we hadn't encountered
any of her dialogue yet it was all
exposition and then it hit us
a full line of her characters actually
speaking to another not just grunting
but speaking in language
it sent us over the top listen
[Music]
hunger raged inside her demanding to be
seated
wicked thumbs teased her too sensitive
flesh
and stole her breath but it would mean
nothing
if he didn't understand you're all
i've ever wanted
wicked thumbs will we ever
going forward ever be able to call
stacey abrams anything but
wicked thumbs we'll see probably not
the book is called hidden sins and
frankly we feel like we've just sinned
in public you can have that feeling too
for the low low price of just seven
dollars
get it but go easy on your thighs
it'll wear them out hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else